foreign
[Music]
you guys welcome back to the break room
Our Daily Show that keeps you updated on
all the nerdy news you need to know
today's show is brought to you by Pluto
TV which offers 100 or hundreds of free
live channels and thousands of free
on-demand movies 100 plus 100 plus and
you know what else is 100 plus today
what Ant-Man oh baby you guys all today
we're going to be talking about Ant-Man
so if there's any other headlines we're
going to save them for tomorrow because
today we just need to talk about that
Quantum realm and I would I'm here Coy's
here yeah I'm here I'm not popping into
Sean Evans later no no we're we're
ourselves I don't know where's Tommy
Jessica can you hear me Tommy where
Tommy where are you I'm in quantumania
and let me tell you the secret that
Janet was keeping from her family is
that it is banging down here it's like
Daytona Beach I'm having the time of my
life oh my gosh what where's down here
yeah what's it like down there oh it's a
balmy 72 degrees the sky is a confusing
swirl of purples blacks and blues and
pinks and I'll be honest with you the uh
local ladies of quantumania and the
quantum realm are pretty fond of the big
T-man if you know what I'm saying Tommy
come on you got to get back up to this
realm we need you on the show we can't
do the show without you I mean do we are
you in my drink I keep looking there's
like some Electronics maybe you know
what I think we could do the show at
that time yeah thank you you know what
Tommy go ahead follow your bliss down
there wherever you are uh uh hey guys I
am just now hearing from some of the
local uh Tavern Keepers they don't have
peacock streaming I'm gonna need you
guys to blast me back into the regular
world so that I can watch the Buffalo
Bills destroy the Green Bay Packers only
on peacock Sunday Night Football call me
how do we even get you back oh I
programmed a very confusing secret code
into the X-Men arcade game oh well
what's the code up up down down left
right left right A B start Tommy that's
literally the Konami Code from Contra on
Nintendo like everyone knows that code
well if it ain't broke don't fix it all
right well give me a minute uh Jessica
hit him with the Redemption okay you
guys uh if we hit 250 in super chats all
I hear is him
laughs
did it work whoa baby oh my God he's
hideous what happened to you down there
what what's wrong is there something
with my face oh no I guess it's the same
okay
it's a face rose welcome back it's good
to be back uh I'm sorry that there's not
as many people it's not 72 degrees
I got my perfect earth round lady right
oh 616. uh and you guys if we had 250 in
super chats today we're gonna stick
around in the quantum realm or maybe
Send Tommy back
and then for our break room we'll get a
little extra time to answer your burning
questions with Quantum Mania yeah yeah
send in all your questions uh we're
gonna get to as many as we can today but
yeah if we hit that 250 we'll stick
around for a little extra stoppage time
that's what I said I know I'm just
agreeing with you you got it hit it you
got to get it I'm gonna send you back
I'm gonna send you to the first one
answer real quick Zach asked is it
painful to get pulled out of the quantum
realm I've had more painful pull-offs in
my life but uh it was pretty painful
remember when you had to tape your hair
to Zach's chest
emotionally painful for him for me to
watch at home yeah
I didn't know what I was in foreign
people let's get into this discussion
let's do it let's talk about it man we
assume you've all seen the trailer by
announce we're not going to play it
again not for you simps okay we're just
gonna dive right into it okay I think my
biggest question from all of this is
like who do we think Bill Murray is
portraying in this in this film I got a
theory you have a theory
Okay so we've met the collector we've
met the Grand Master we've got ego The
Living Planet there's only a few more of
the Elders of the universe and if we're
dealing with Cosmic and quantifiable
abstract entities I think we need a very
certain Elder who would tie into time
and that is Father Time
time Bill Murray would be the perfect
person to be kind of the gatekeeper
between these Realms and also would tie
into this like Elder the universe World
Plus you've got like that Bill Murray
Benicio del Toro energy and then you add
you know Jeff gold but he fits the tone
of what they built so far guys like them
in the same room did I earn this no I'm
like I have a question
by the way I guess we would stay the
same size though you know you were
holding on to it that's true you're
right what was your question um oh yeah
did it just get big when you came back
to normal size two
um my question is is Father time
um
it's because like you think he's going
to be left in this uh in the movie we
won't see him again moving forward I
mean I think if we do a secret Wars or
if we get to the the broader like the
beyonder and all the things that the
abstract becomes like the Living
Tribunal and those things I think he
could be a man out of space and time so
he could manipulate what's going on in
there and also okay so I guess that goes
to my second question how important do
you think he is
okay I think he's going to be important
for this film and then I think he's even
important for Secret Wars but I don't
think he's going to be overall yeah so I
think he's going to be like we'll see
him again as an elder if he is this
character and I think he'll be key here
but screen time-wise small importance
medium I'm here for that can I ask a
question uh on behalf of the audience I
obviously know the answer but for the
audience uh does every this is where I
get confused sometimes this is every
Multiverse have their own versions of
Elder Gods because you know how
celestials kind of live outside of the
Multiverse and project themselves into
each one so some things are outside of
the the universe uh Collective right so
like the Living Tribunal is above all
that so there's one Living Tribunal yeah
so there are certain entities certain
Cosmic deities that are above all so
like we met the uh uh the character in
uh love and thunder that was eternity
right right yeah eternity would be kind
of a doorway connected right so that's
like a hole in the fabric of it so you'd
have these Elders that are kind of
seeing all of in the figure Comic-Con
right they'd be like viewing all of it
manipulating it but kind of able to be
in multiple platforms at time at once
sure and that's what I also think we're
gonna be dealing with with Kang is we're
going to be starting to see that like we
can have one thing like the the rose
Einstein Rosenberg bridge where you fold
space time poke a hole through it like
we talked about Natalie Portman was
describing how that goes I think that's
what Kang is going to be able to do he's
like at a weird kind of he's a Nexus
right so he can kind of control what's
been between so I think these deities
are going to be much like Kang and that
they're able to ignore me b b between
space time so if we get secret Wars and
we fold all these realities which I
think is how we get these variants
that's going to be these creatures yeah
and draw something I have a question
so this is how um you drew the Realms
and what you might call it so you're
making me drop do it so
um we said that these are the Realms
right right outside of the um uh this
looks like something I saw in biology
what did we it wasn't Dimensions it's uh
uh uh like Dimensions I think that like
the way I Envision it is like go to this
really quick you have universes okay
that kind of exists like we saw that in
Loki right at the in the season finale
when there's like two black holes right
those are like their own universes but
in between universes can kind of exist
Dimensions right but I think that like
each universe may not have its own
Dimension with the dimensions of the
connective tissue between them right
yeah so I think like what causes
incursions right is when they mess with
the dark dimension that's in between the
space that's keeping them yes and that's
what makes them bleed into each other
and that's what I think they're gonna do
sorry no keep going I think that's what
they're gonna do with annihilus and the
negative Zoom right in the comic books
the negative zone is where the Fantastic
Four trap things kind of like Superman
throws Zod and you don't mean like it's
like that I can see them doing the
Negative Zone as that threshold right
that could be where as the dimension the
the middle Dimension
between the stuff in between we I know
that we're like kind of unclear about
what the quantum realm is so where were
Quantum realm is it just everywhere yeah
well I say it's below and you blow out
Tommy says down upside down and
ironically I think it's below yeah I
kind of see it kind of as koi is
describing where it it's almost like
that point yeah yeah and through there
you can kind of transfer to other places
because it's definitely small right it's
infinitely small so when you say it's a
Nexus point
it's it can be it just is anyway I would
imagine every different Universe would
be able to go into this connecting
tissue right it's like the the so it
does not matter where it is in the
Realms and the dimensions I think it
it's also like we can't map it oh my oh
my gosh
this episode is already the most when we
get into when we get into the discussion
of even Nexus events that are just like
Quantum Realms drunk as hell
I am too dumb for this okay I've been
looking at Little Birdies flying around
in my head if time is relative right so
when like for example in Civil War
enchantment giant man gets big he looks
like he's moving slow because to him
time is relativity or look at like
Interstellar right the further away you
get from something the more time moves
quickly at the original Source Point so
I imagine in the quantum realm they're
gonna be if they're there in their week
it's gonna be years on the planet just
like we experienced with Scott so I
think that time displacement allows for
a greater distance so it can be a
connective tissue because time is
relative so if you shrink down to
infinite tiny space that could connect
all things because it could be the the
the space-time connection it comes down
to us no go ahead no no go ahead I guess
it I I mean it comes down to the time
and me and Brandon have tried to do like
any kind of science math for these
situations so I guess any place you are
for the quantum realm is like even if
you're in this small and you're in a koi
shoulder reaching China is nothing to
that it's just infinite the speed it
takes you to get there would be like
nothing or is it just because the
quantum realm is just so vast but so
small well it's also a problem of we as
human beings experience things a certain
way we live in a three-dimensional space
and we experience time progressively and
literally yeah it's a vector for us yeah
so it is almost impossible for us to
like even understand the concept of like
the fourth dimension and how to move
through it like there's the ideas in our
world that there are four dimension
creatures that exist among us we
literally just can't even see them well
it was experience it with space right
yeah people come back and they're a
different age and when we send stuff far
enough out we've experienced that on a
tiny scale so we've seen that distance
does con cause time disparities and that
was the concept of time travel and end
game was if you got small enough you
want yourself out of it at the right
time you'll leap out into another time
because you've gotten small enough
that's why I think it connects all
things because if you get small enough
then time as we know it doesn't exist
and that's why I think this might be
this mcu's version of the Negative Zone
slash Phantom okay okay
let me break it down for you people hit
it hit it hit him with it Tommy
you can have pizza in the morning you
can have pizza in the evening you can
have pizza at supper time because when
pizza's on a bagel ah you can eat pizza
anytime time
flat circle with little pepperonis and
cheese and sauce on it it's an
everything I make a pizza bagel
time is a pizza bag everything
everywhere all at ones pizza bagel
Edition that's right we actually have we
have a big question about how time is a
big part of this movie we're gonna say
that for the end of this discussion okay
what should we talk about next Jessica
is
yeah
if you like this insane conversation hit
that like button if you hate this
conversation yeah and by the way if you
want more uh science yeah go subscribe
to National Geographic if you want more
nerd stuff subscribe to us you simps
we're not we're not tied down by them or
subscribe to ASAP the bonds of facts
ASAP science not here I love ASAP
science that's why I watch a lot of
science breakdowns on YouTube I like
that I watch science breakdowns on
YouTube You're an alert
seven swans are swimming
six Keys
he's so excited for Christmas I can't
wait Tuesday Morning Christmas begins on
the break room hello
it's one of the few holidays the Irish
brought here and got to keep let us know
all right little [ __ ] Thanksgiving
like slicing up a turkey and fist
fighting with your uncle
brought this conversation the light
Irish Halloween Australian Thanksgiving
Christmas for all yes oh my God black
history month so uh our next question
this is my cell phone next question what
is the secret that Janet had set we have
a little clip right here of it
no what are you so afraid of
there's something I never told you
your secret is not that she's afraid to
layer a dynamite outfit Cape over tunic
over long sleeve I'm getting tired of
all these these hooded capes showing up
in different fantasies that are colorful
right if they were white we'd be
concerned I didn't find that after the
dragon is showing you put a cape and a
hood on somebody you don't know who it
is well that's a crime hoodie that's
what I like about this trailer with
Janet was I'm like what did I think you
did something bad wow you were up to no
good girl you're just talking about an
alcoy and like time you know remember
Scott was down there for five years in
our time yeah but for him it was like
just a few moments right was Janet
secretly did she live like for hundreds
of years down yeah I mean she wouldn't
have had to I mean
did she make a deal with kids to like
restore her to what the age she was
supposed to be with did she and Daddy
Kane is that why she wants no
communication I'm not kidding this is a
real thing is that why she's like shut
it down do not call him he's kind of my
ex yeah he did a thing to restore me to
the appropriate age to not Shock you
guys but I had actually lived lives I
had other children I had other marriages
who thought she was down there forever I
was throwing that thing around in the
comics amortis in the comic books who's
on my shirt so I wore this shirt because
there's a lot of shirts with keg it's
hard to find in the comics a mortis uh
is in love with someone that he travels
through time for and the recent 2021
King miniseries was all about the
official origin of Kang being that he
literally had to destroy his own sense
of love in order to become the Conqueror
he had to go back through time in order
to stop being in love with this woman
because he'd go to all the different
variations of King hood and he'd
basically fail at saving her So
eventually he had to kill that version
himself that that version of who loved
her in order to become the Conqueror
what if Kang did love Michelle Pfeiffer
and therefore had to become the
Conqueror by William no sorry I read it
I read a comment in the chat that said
Jessica has the worst theories I didn't
even theorize anything in it yeah what
all right listen to me Bill Murray is
Janet's son now that I like Aaron at law
uh
Kang and Janet's son Karnak
the son of Kang and Janet Bill Murray
huh huh I like that we're just throwing
wild theories I like the idea that she
she does owe something
um that she's up to something well she
comes back let's think about when she
came back at him in the WASP right she
shows back up on the scene she's she's
been infecting Scott's mind because they
had a connection when he was down there
before and he had those little wispies
according to the scene they put into the
sequel and so then he's like having
visions of her memories that and he
reconnects and that's because uh hope
and Hank were messing with the quantum
tunnel they'd opened it up and that's
when Janet was able to like boom ping
into his mind kind of like what she's
worried about here right if you open up
some sort of portal or like connection
to the quantum realm something can come
back out right uh is it is it that she
you know she's trying to hide where her
like Powers came from because she came
up back with these Powers too right and
all she says is like the quantum World
changed me did it change you did you
murder thousands of people in the
quantum realm to absorb their powers I
mean imagine if she's down there for a
very very long time assume she's never
gonna get out yeah she's like well I
just gotta roll with this now maybe I'll
kill everyone down here
I murdered a bunch of people yeah yeah
no one's wearing a breathing mask who
knows what they're doing the trailer uh
so far we didn't really see anyone
really attacking her they were they were
coming at everyone else but her so far
except for Hank I think of to be fair
I've only watched her like three times
but it looked like they were coming for
Cassie they were coming for Scott they
came for wasp but I didn't see them
really come for Janet yet so maybe Janet
does have like some protectiveness
around her maybe it's possible it's
possible the chat isn't for me this is
Karnak and I'm a little embarrassed
because uh I and I was okay well well
because if you look at the mortise he
looks like that but also Karnak I'm used
to the more modern Karnak this I guess
could be him guys Karnak and Kang look
very similar I'm sorry stop coming back
people on this don't come for our house
I didn't Eric Fawcett he would have
known I'm so sorry
to get as much out on a Monday as they
can because they know the trash man
comes on Tuesday to take them away from
their home so
that's all right pull on your newspaper
blankets and uh get a nice night's sleep
tonight because tomorrow
the bill comes due
um so the bill comes too
the bill comes perfect are all of the
Kings the same or will we see uh
kangariums you think it is interesting
because when we this is there's a lot of
different footage here from what was at
d23 right yeah but flavors of it are
different flavors and my changed lines
there's some stuff they don't get into
that they said in the trailer though I
mean you can't really know because who
knows we'll get cut from the movie the
movie itself will be Canon no matter
what deleted scenes or whatever they
change that's fine I uh I really like
the idea that this Kang was sent there
by the other king that this was
banishment for our King that we're
seeing in the quantum row okay so both
scenes might be Canon because of that
because I could see them being like Oh
have I killed you before being the
iconic line we got before yeah maybe
this this scene is also in there where
there's there's rep like you know the
introduction strange we get to see
different variations of the Kang and how
we'd handle that situation maybe this
one knows Ant-Man and that's why we hire
Ant-Man I also loved in the trailer the
totality ship between the Spider-Man
joke and the your Ant-Man because it
goes from being like I don't matter
enough I matter too much right like this
is I don't want you to know please don't
know my name so that might be like
variants of Kang we've even seen in our
footage I was so happy to see the blue
mask yeah I have the d23 I also didn't
remember the the scars on his face I
thought the scars were more severe at
d23 because there were stars in San
Diego San Diego footage no scars
or is it different I think they're
different Kings and that was also done
in post I think San Diego Kang and d23
King and this King might be all
different kicks I there was definitely
there's a few small tweaks around this
trailer than what we saw d23 for sure
just like change like that final scene
where he's talking to Ant-Man and he's
like you're Ant-Man or whatever he says
we saw that same kind of setup yeah
we'll take the same space and that's
where you said have I killed you before
it wasn't a blast
I feel like they went with that macro
right they zoomed out more like we
didn't see nearly the scope yeah because
everyone knows the trailer from d23 now
so they probably were like
used telekinesis to like throw Scout up
against the wall yeah we saw more power
right and we all said more time with
Kang aroo it was just like a longer
probably because they hadn't done all
these VFX shots
if we see other Kang variants in the
quantum Realm you think they were either
bandaged there or they just are residing
how would you see so many yeah wouldn't
they be fighting down there right it's
like you can't they're betta fish kings
are betta fish
yeah space so they'll just like we might
see Ken take out kangs and that'll show
us like the Russian nesting doll of
badassery is is there I mean correct me
if I'm wrong uh all of you who who know
the comics a little bit of me is it the
quantum realm frequently kind of used as
a hiding spot too for people like doom
and Kane like don't they kind of hide
out in there so like they can't be
detected that's why I think he's been
right like I think I think he might
enjoy being down there right now well I
feel like there's one that can get in
there one that does is like specifically
like an enthusiastic
a time traveling Enthusiast I think they
all are but I think there's one you know
do you guys so there are rumors and some
people in the chat have even said that
uh uh Scott is uh his uh variant is Bill
Murray do you think we'll see other
Scotland variants I think yes I think we
will see you in the quantum realm I
think we're gonna see a bunch of Scott
Scott Langs I think we're gonna see just
uh some some Paul Red Sky wings I think
there's some good great opportunity for
some Cameo Scott Langs uh if you're it's
just there has to be multiple instances
throughout the Multiverse of an Ant-Man
who goes to the quantum realm and is
unable to get back well I'm wondering if
we see like a like a like a
a body pile of Kang having pulled
different scotlings and only knowing
Scott Lang is who can help him but
pulling in the wrong Scott Langs and
then just kind of being like also I
don't think it's a coincidence that the
character we've seen time travel first
is Scott Lang right and the Hulk doing
this no yeah 100 like Hulk's doing those
experiments I wonder if any of those are
like you know pop up and that ties into
what we're experiencing like yeah let's
go here which we might get into so it
stop me if this is something I'll stop
you so this is uh this is also how I
feel with Cassie so
we might get into this so please stop
I'm so sorry okay so one of my questions
was who did Cassie build the signal with
here's a little clip of it
people still need help Dad that's why we
made this
like a satellite for deep space but
Quanah
yeah it's a big question of like this is
why we build this and we see everyone's
different reaction and maybe I think
clearly like because uh Hank is not
doesn't he's not as Afflicted as the
rest of them are but do you think she
made this in prison with someone else do
you think she was in like a prison that
is like different and she was like I
engineered this with someone well it's
very weird right because Hank in that
very weird Club Hank's kind of smiling
at first yeah he's like trap Grandpa and
then as soon as like Janet's like wait
what he his face kind of goes yeah yeah
what I think I'm about my grandfather
daughter bonding time like that might
have been a family build I hate to keep
going back to Detroit three but do you
remember in that trailer it established
that Cassie had been like arrested right
do you know how when you bring up the
gym no I I think it was just like last
night or this afternoon
a small thing
um and then she also says something
along the lines of like while you were
gone in the quantum realm like we were
worried about it or we were trying to
find a way to get to you or something
like that so I don't know who this we is
but in that instance it couldn't be Hank
because Hank
reduction maybe it was uh it could be
Celery Man oyster or tame tame yeah
porcupine yeah
do we know if there's anyone that Cassie
has um interacted with a lot of Like
Comics heavily that maybe which I do
think is going to tie into the king
stuff because he's a Young Avengers one
through six that whole Arc is Kang based
so there could be a lot of tie-ins to
what Young Avengers are gonna be post
this well it also has to be someone
that's like an engine engineering like
Engineering in this form of like let's
enter a Quantum let's send a signal
in wakanda but that's my question is
does she have uh I know a lot of party
established her in Chicago
she's in San Francisco she's in hey with
time travel you can do anything ask her
mom that's my question is like is she
gonna be focusing more on the
engineering aspect effects of what we
can physically acquire right now or is
she actually working on getting into the
quantum realm it doesn't seem like
that's something ironheart was doing
where's Bruno going he's going to
Caltech yeah he's wearing the other side
of the country wait San Francisco and
Caltech is there a count Tech you think
she was building it with Bruno with
Bruno if he moved on yeah
like superheroes I like you know what I
gotta get out of this he's like the last
thing I want to do is get with another
the chat
iron lad yeah yeah I mean Iron lad does
canonically turn into Kang so it'd be
kind of fun if they had that twist where
we meet a young iron lad and then we
find out later that he's Kang and he has
to fight his future self or he has to
fight Cassie are these people okay I
gotta read these cops
Franklin Richards is King like Franklin
so wait it's like the king I don't want
to be gross well most of them died in
the sperm of Reed Richards and then and
then and then the or the Egg of uh of
zoo storm and then become a king realm
is that I mean I'm saying like I I want
to know or were they just like or did he
like steal the real Franklin Richards
and like Chuck him out the nursery
window and lay then become a baby and
grow up I love the concept of Kang
inside of a robotic Mech sperm hiding in
the Fallopian tubes of of Sue storm yes
and every time Sue and uh Richard is
what they would like to do
I think it was GSG Eagle said when we
were talking about the names of
different cake variants someone said
booty k
Nathaniel Richards so sorry nerds sorry
sorry Nathaniel Richards not Franklin
Richmond directions
keep becoming teenagers and then they
grow up in these things how do the
parents not know you can't go back in
time and kill Baby Hitler it's the same
problem I just don't get say it to me
like I'm the dumbest man he just did you
can't go back
you're going to just okay so they become
kings in the future yes yeah so they're
boring so Nathaniel Richards is just
nothing right now and then eventually
when he's like 45 he's like I'm actually
gonna be king so could I declare myself
a king so there are different
continuities where he travels through
time and loses that love and then he
becomes evil because that thing he can't
get no matter what time it is and so
Kang is more of a state of mind I mean
is kingified well sometimes sometimes
you find out you're a Kang and you're
like I don't want to be a king yeah
your universe is King but you had no
idea okay so it's like a title like
there could only be one dread pirate
Roberts right but it's just a guy in a
mess yeah okay I got it guys I got it
catch up with me after on uh Telegram
I love it it's just people that think
like me uh we all inhale a bunch of
paint and then we go ah Joe Biden's
Obama in a mask
cut that for the broadcast uh what what
do we think that Kang is looking to
Scott for because that that's kind of a
big
thing here it's like you have this
powerful looking King who's in we'll
call it chronopolis for lack of a better
word like this hidden city which Peyton
Reed has confirmed that we did see
chronopolis when they were like leaving
and Iron Man whatever it was kind of
hiding in the background he's got this
huge Army
ships Jets or whatever why can't he get
out of the quantum room if he's so
powerful I don't think he wants to he
needs Scott to get out of it I think
there's a there's a situ sorry
I think there's a specific
time and place when he needs to bust out
and he needs Scott to help him so he's
building everything he's getting
everything ready I now am an expert in
what king is right yeah
I have become a king I've realized that
I am this Earth's gang and let me tell
you business is good for old KD can't
daddy uh so he's getting ready to burst
out with all those ships and all those
uh Bros and ladies and uh and he just
needs Scott to get him out at the right
time and you need Scott's uh I have a
feeling it's obviously something to do
with the shrinking and growing huge I
think Kang wants to become giant Kang
Super King
like maybe he needs the pen particles
for whatever he needs some PP 's he
needs a PPE look let me tell you I need
a PP so
hey yo
yo I sort of agree with Tommy I I mainly
agree oh [ __ ] clip that out
the technology that was able to send the
signal into the quantum realm is the
same technology he's going to need in
the quantum realm to get out but he
can't build it with the stuff that he
has and I also think if there is a bunch
of different Kings in there it would
make sense that one king was like I need
to get out before the other kings do but
I don't have the means to do it I do
need help from you and he's going to
find out that it was Cassie that created
it not yeah he's gonna think it's the
Time Heist that you know he'd be famous
for if you think about it in we opened
with the thing him being so famous right
he's the one that saved everyone people
might know that he's the one that helped
in time travel so maybe Kang thinks that
he's the one that invented this thing
yes Kane thinks it's the man but it's
really the woman behind the man and
isn't that true about all great men
there's a strong woman behind them to
bolster them up
uh
you think some great men just stand on
their own oh God okay why don't you
respect women more Jessica wow this is
very trouble is this is all troubling uh
I do like this idea that he that there's
going to be some sort of heist element
to this that's what's in every Ant-Man
movie right there's always the highest
time the second one's all about like oh
I'm done I'm not going to do that
anymore he's like well I need you to do
it again it's like all right well here
we go uh yeah because what could King
possibly need from a Skyline but if this
is the only Universe where time travel
has worked oh right maybe he's like
obsessed with that and he knows he can
use that uh to get out
um what's up with the stringy boys what
are we talking about with that pictures
of stringy boys
oh wait can you move foreign
[Music]
Madness they said let's do it again yeah
I think they like you I think those
stringy boys go together I think that
maybe if your time displaced and when
you get pulled back in your timeline or
something you get like you unravel like
time unraveling so that would be someone
that's fully displaced and they get
ripped apart so sorry partially
displaced like maybe that guy survived a
displacement
is it two of them or is it just one of
them we're saying incursions koi you're
saying some incursions I'm saying it
could be incursions could just be like
when time is righted like think about
the TVA right when those split we don't
know what happens to the people in those
in those times what if they're just
normal people and that's the people in
there when we watch a trailer I pause at
the scene where we can see everyone and
you see like the light bulb kind of the
head person and a couple other people
and I was like there's just so many
different types of people here it's kind
of like what is the Wanda of the quantum
realm spaghettied them like she did Mr
Fantastic
do you think there do you guys think
they're both the same stringy boys the
one that's in the Ant-Man the giant
Ant-Man string and this no I think this
guy is a not fully dismembered stringy
boy and the Ant-Man we got full stringy
boy I think when time displacement goes
extreme you get full stringy I think
when you save yourself he partial string
boy I think that's just gonna I think
the giant string boy is gonna we started
so well with science now we're barely
saying words I think the ultimate you
Ant-Man is an illusion created by a Kang
variant that's already in there and is
trying to stop them from reaching
whatever goal he's running to and it's
like I'm gonna make you see things kind
of how like um Mysterio did it to Peter
Parker I want that kind of scene it was
like you're gonna be trapped in mirrors
for a second yeah
when Hulk was kind of experimenting on
time travel before Tony came to help
them where uh time was passed through
this guy yeah and he became old and
young when he was going in and out like
at some point in those in and outs you
could swap Scott right and maybe we've
been stuck with a Scott a way that is
not our original Sky oh and maybe the
original Scott is still down there and
like he was the one trying to send out a
signal because I don't even know if it's
Kang coming out I wonder if like they
wind up down there and it wasn't Kang
that brought them down there it was
someone else old bringing them down what
if kid Scott in end game is Bill Murray
now oh okay
what if that's been the journey that's
what I was gonna say got free
uh all this talk of time though this was
like a very interesting clip because
from everything they had Kang say which
is not much he he says he could give
Scott more time I think we have a little
clip of it from the trailer here I can
get you home
and give you more time
not enough and maybe I'm wrong I just
haven't seen I haven't been on Twitter
most of today I tweeted that and I went
on what a flat how have you been looking
at Twitter
what I meant to say is that
um it is that's a really big deal the
fact that he's like I can give you more
time and it's like what do you mean you
can give me more time you're just gonna
make time slower or faster here in the
quantum realm or you're gonna make it
you can control that that's that's why
it makes like this time thing I think
that to team up and there's a heist and
then like he keeps failing at it a lot
of the people in Top Gun and then top
gun Maverick Tom Cruise comes in has
more time handles it Kang is the the Tom
Cruise of this scenario question I think
that somehow what happened to Janet Van
Dyne in the quantum realm and her kind
of work around to have not aged as much
as she should have is going to start
happening to Scott he's going to realize
all of his messing around with the
quantum realm is making him age maybe
mentally maybe he's starting to develop
some like Dementia or things like that
and the more time Kang is saying is he
can help him the way he helped Janet if
he helps if Scott helps Kang I can give
you more time I could stop you from
aging out maybe Paul Rudd is trying to
exit on out of the old MCU you know he's
you know like uh like he's been around
for a long time maybe he's done and the
whole thing is that Ant-Man is going to
be rapidly aging of a Jack from the
Robin Williams I think maybe the more
time thing is I can slow this down
you're going to start rapidly aging
because you messed around with time and
you found out yeah I could start with in
game like they could even tie into like
the beginning when it all you know like
this was a catalyst that you did and
I've been helping I I like that I like
that especially because it's like Janet
and Hank are probably dying
maybe not Janet so much because maybe
she did get something when she came out
the first time but like Hank is probably
I mean his order of concern is
definitely like his daughter first right
now you have hope uh who is like a big
meaning to him but if something's up
with Cassie like that could you could
make Scott do anything right that is his
way and we didn't see her in prison
another prison it looked like she was in
the suit in prison maybe he's saying I
can give you more time in prison with
your daughter or maybe he's saying like
the you're she's just gonna go back to
prison he can like oh he's like this is
all it's gonna happen when you leave and
I could give you more time here it's all
a documentary and it's how Paul Rudd has
stayed clueless age this whole time I
just hope that I found out stem cells
maybe he knows Cassie's gonna die maybe
Kang somehow has Intel that Cassie's
gonna die and has like maybe he has like
like uh Microtech that no she has some
sort of terminal disease and he's saying
I can give you more time with her we
could theorize about this all day guys I
just hope that Denzel shows up and he
says I wish you you had more time you
man on fire check it out I hate you I
thought it was a movie about times
no I thought you're gonna take it away
Justin Timberlake's about time that's we
only got five times
you know anymore
no time to die There's A Time to Kill
we're almost 48 hours we're almost
halfway to our goal of adding a little
stoppage time
yes uh I'm gonna say it one more time
you're wasted it I didn't mean to okay
time too I'll not say it but yeah with
we're almost halfway to our goal yeah
and with that goal we will definitely
Explore More of Modoc because Modoc is
going to be featured in this and we
haven't talked about it but I'm not
going to talk about Monaco
thus far uh one last thing before we
think the sponsors of this show do we
think like time dilation is gonna affect
the rest of the MCU or obviously okay
this is like Kang's big entrance into
the to this uh Multiverse Saga right he
was in Loki yes but like this is the big
screen Big Time Kang for most people so
like there's gonna be some aftershocks
that Ripple throughout the MCU uh in
this movie is time gonna be that thing
wait you think what's gonna happen in
the quantum realm is going to Ripple
throughout the quad I think I think this
movie is gonna have to have some major
effects I think so on the rest of the
MCU and I don't think it this movie's
gonna wrap things up I think it's gonna
be like it's gonna leave like a big
problem but we kind of need that right
because so far all we've been just
getting is little breadcrumbs about
what's to come you know I think we need
some some uh giant gaping wounds in the
story you know what I mean Time Bandits
by the way do you think that um we go
Minute Men do you think
um that they're going to be in the
quantum realm for so long that when they
come out and like wait in the future
even if they're under a month that could
be years
when maybe Cassie Lane gets out and
she's able to Young Avenger up but
everyone else has been there for a long
time that was the big thing of Ant-Man
too right was like distraction right
like while you were over here dealing
with this problem I messed things up
over here is like did Kane bring them
down there just to get them out of the
way so he could mess with the rest of
the world or maybe he sent another of
his variants to deal with them and he's
out there because King Dynasty is the
whole MCU yeah yeah so that's I mean
it's a secret War title it's an Avenger
Time oh my gosh we have some fun people
in the chat that are saying like I think
Janet and Hank are gonna die this movie
because they're Ant-Man and wasp in the
comic book that's right like what if
what if the title's about them what if
they want to be young forever
and what we saw in the trailer is like
one of the first acting when they're
gone and then it's about Hank and Jamie
I would love some scenes of the OG
Ant-Man and the WASP like that'd be
incredible to see them in their Prime in
the 60s I would love to see some
original scenes of them and then I'd
love to see them get graphically
butchered and killed we'd like to thank
butcherbox for sponsoring today's break
oh my god listen I used to buy all my
turkey from the supermarket like a gosh
dang sick where else would you get
turkey from well that's what I'm about
to tell you it was loaded with
antibiotics and it didn't have the taste
I want out of the star of Thanksgiving
okay Enter butcher box I was able to get
hormone free antibiotic free turkey
delivered right to my door with butcher
box I get peace of mind when it comes to
buying meat butcherbox takes the
guesswork out of finding high quality
Meat and seafood you can trust 100
grass-fed beef free-range organic
chicken pork raise crate free wild
caught seafood and I'm talking real wild
partying all night on a bender Seafood
caught out of the ocean it's always
humanely raised with no antibiotics or
added hormones as I said before get what
you want delivered right to your
doorstep I'm talking free shipping for
the continental U.S whoa and there ain't
no surprise fees with butcher box ding
dong this is what you paid for this is
what you're getting no surprise fees no
Kings popping up juice from a variety of
box plans from curated to customized and
change the plan whenever you want now
listen you all know me I'm a mess
it's a never-ending Quest eat better and
save money put your boxes my new
teammate and we are heading towards the
goal line baby like Josh Allen throwing
a Stefan Diggs on a Sunday night
said no Buffalo Bills references during
the address well they also got buffalo
grass fed okay now the main course for
Thanksgiving dinner can sometimes be a
main source of stress not anymore you
simps butcher boxes off and our
listeners
free turkey with their first order sign
up today at butcherbox.com
and use code break room to get 10 to 14
to get a 10 to 14 pound turkey free in
your first box that's a turkey the size
of a heavy bowling ball okay that's
butcherbox.com break room you gotta use
the code break room to claim this deal
the new New England Patriots or the
bills that's not even close to true
that's such an offensive incorrect
statement but what is a correct
statement is we want to thank Pluto TV
for sponsoring the break room all week
and our house of dragons finale
breakdowns right plus Pluto tv offers
hundreds of free live channels and
thousands of free on-demand movies you
don't need nothing else with Pluto TV
can't say anything else that's it we're
done now
if you haven't hit the like button on
this video I want you to stop what
you're doing right now and hit like if
you haven't subscribed to our Channel
yet I don't know what you gotta do I
have you know maybe change your attitude
and get your family to like you again
because there's something really wrong
with you if you haven't subscribe to us
oh my gosh no friend of mine doesn't
subscribe to this channel you see me in
the streets and I find out you're not
subbed we're gonna go at it and I'm
talking tickle fights okay now Tommy A
Time to Kill it's time for mandatory fun
that's right
the segments though the segment's so
silly that we take some time to
celebrate the Phillies headed to the
World Series hit it again
congrats to all my Philadelphia P what's
the World Series you just sat there and
Drew of uvula or not a uvula a a vaginal
canal with two ovaries like you're
seeing a vaginal kid now I've been told
they're quite Pleasant
for me to mandatory fine
that's why I find the segments so
sexually inexperienced we play the
graphic because we're Furious hit it
again
don't call yourself yes mandatory fun
the segment's so pure we play the
graphic with Fury
it is again thank God I dreaded that one
all right now
the Ant-Man trailer dropped we've been
talking about it all day long
man all right now it was packed with
some familiar faces we also saw some new
faces we wanted to introduce those
people to you so guys I asked each one
of you to pick a newcomer and give us a
little background let's show the picture
I'm gonna go first who's this guy this
is popping up first show them there's
some real backgrounds for these
characters yeah take a look at this guy
you have no good car ideas this is Horus
Dingle okay all right sorry he wasn't
always a barista many years ago he was
part of a secret government program
known as [ __ ]
what's that program that's the Strategic
Homeland Android technicians [ __ ]
I think Strategic Homeland Android
technicians why doesn't it make sense
what does it make sense about it
um don't yell at me I'm not yelling at
you but if you're gonna interject that
doesn't make sense I feel like you got
to back that up you know some of them
some of the Agents of chat they would
lay on the ground so they'd be the
Strategic Homeland Android recumbent
tickets that's right
yeah they were known as sometimes you
don't you don't know if it's just a shot
it's just a little shark sometimes you
think you shat but it's dry and that's
what it's just known as a
which is the party Homeland Android
technicians and friendly technicians
listen I've kissed the girl before
that's not debatable I'll bring them on
the show okay anyone's saying I haven't
I haven't kissed a girl before I'll
bring three of them
Boris Dingle wasn't always a barista no
he used to work for a secret government
program nice [ __ ] we covered that
unfortunately Horus got a little
sidetracked he was obsessed with only
building androids for Pleasures I'm
talking suckers I'm talking Tuckers
hey hey hey I didn't write this movie I
didn't write this movie you can't be mad
at me you can't be mad at me I didn't
like this movie should be mad at Jeff be
mad at Jeff Lopez my close friend hit
the picture you don't have it because
you don't want me to succeed on this
show all right what is it happening I've
had three Coke Zeros today and I stopped
drinking a week ago he's designing LM
Double D's and it's alarming it's gone
places all right now
he soon was on the outs with the
government and Public Enemy Number One
of Howard Stark who was building a
similar pleasure robot okay all right so
he left Chef he is single despite
working at a coffee shop his beverage of
choices Code Red Mountain Dew that's
good to know he's allergic to bees and
wasps oh ironic and his catchphrase is
that's a nice looking Roomba can I spend
some time alone with it Thomas
as beautifully but uh yeah here we are
with this is Arya rachnid now he's a
bartender in the microverse and life
hasn't gone as expected for oldari after
getting pulled over in his micro Mustang
last year he was cited for driving while
small that's right it's a DWS and his
wife left him and took their 3 000
children after meeting a Micronaut at
the app splatter unfortunately he wasn't
able to contact chat in time and solve
his overly abundant sperm problem now he
spends his days slinging drinks and
trying to hustle people at darts which
he sucks at now he is open to a new
relationship isn't going to rush
anything just yet because he's a
reasonable man he's got a lot of kids
he's in the spider-verse he's also
coming out in Sony spider verse two he's
coming no he plays fantasy football but
always forgets to enter his lineup on
time so it's friends all hate him what a
jerk it's a rough life now is
catchphrase is eff it I'll just order
tiny GrubHub
why did they call it tiny GrubHub I
don't know they were yeah I think that
yeah especially yeah they're down there
looking up at us so far down he saw how
small he was yeah guys I've been to the
microverse I've been to quantumania I've
seen chat
it's everywhere down there
Thomas
this is an adult show for adults that
was funny though that was a good one
I'll give them that
um okay well this is my boy uh his
name's Keith oh okay and can't wait to
show you guys Keith
give it a second
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that's a Kentucky
hey hey hey no one made no one no one
gave me an option okay about adding that
to my name his name is Keith but he
actually goes by and what's funny is he
actually auditioned for stranger things
as the demogorgon but his mouth only
opens vertically
yes he hasn't bloomed yet he was
actually uh built by kangaroo oh okay he
was actually built by Kang as a servant
to protect uh only Kang
um and he's kind of like a violent
version of Miss minutes because she was
also created by Kang has anyone Googled
Father Time destroys Miss minutes
do you want to do this nope sorry
what does that mean
Father Time destroys no no no what does
yours mean what do you mean I don't
understand see that's what you did
during mine
it kind of throws you no I don't want
you to be sorry I just want you to learn
I did I'm so sorry
my feelings are destroyed you had chat
um I have what oh my God either way I'm
sorry I did not mean to interrupt I I
can admit when I'm wrong and I was wrong
for that so he's like a violent version
of Miss minutes his mouth only opens
vertically his name is Keith but he is
actually
um and since Kang was banished to the
quantum Realm by a different variant of
himself he's been tinkering with the
pieces only available within he doesn't
talk much and he doesn't have eyes but
it's completely loyal so I don't know
how long you'll be single ladies and if
you ever get a chance to reach into his
mouth you'll gain a piece of cake
piece of candy
he's always willing to butt in on any
topic you're discussing to give you his
well-researched take on it he's always
happy to do that if you didn't know this
he was a standout athlete in high school
until a fateful game of Varsity Quantum
football that's what they call it down
there resulting in his ACL being
completely destroyed to this day he
walks with a cane to support his
unsteady gate you know Dio Demus he
moved on from me he doesn't let that
affect his life he got married he
started a family but he still can't
shake but might have been oh wow had he
never injured his leg on that fateful
day would he be playing Quantum football
professionally oh my God would he have
moved away from chronopolis and never
met his wife that he currently has oh
God how would his life be different and
you know one night
many years ago he went down this
familiar path of thinking while drowning
his sorrows at a bar what's happening
and uh that's where he first met Janet
Van Dyne oh she was drinking to forget
her life she lost as well you know she
was stuck down they're modeling sorrow
morphed into a night of passion they
both tried to forget but here they are
meeting again
in the quantum realm can I see her also
he can manipulate white particles oh
Jessica Jesus I can't see it well you've
seen the pictures
give me this microphone give me his
microphone I need to I need to address
the elephant in the room
and I'm sorry okay
sorry it's okay I'm sorry forgive you
that I can't see the screen sometimes I
can't see past Dash all the cameraman no
I'm sorry
I felt like you already saw the picture
but you know what if you need to see it
again I'm glad great work everybody that
was mandatory fun the show's over I
think I misunderstood by that I went
down the fanfiction
being down there banging around her way
around the quantum realm and then all of
a sudden she's like oops I can go home
stop being mean to Jessica Danielle
Johnson Jessica is my queen I would
never be me don't read the chat I just
want her to be happy all I want is for
Tommy to be happy all right I'm happy
I'm happy every day I get to spend with
you my love thank you to a lot of our
super Chatters today Jordan halfford
saying Jess is the best uh Lion of
demise was suggesting Bill Murray's
father time would be extra funny because
of Groundhog Day yeah we all know
Groundhog Day uh Mikey cheers about 10
years before you were born yeah I was
born in 2002. that's a good thank you
for reminding me that time thank you two
years saying Pizza bagels for the break
room hashtag damn it Janet I don't
remember damn it Janet
are we gonna dress up this week I I
think we should do I think
we can do whatever we want on Monday but
I think Friday because I'm dressing up
as Boo from Nintendo we should do
Nintendo oh yes Nintendo okay but I
think we should do one other surprise
day this week maybe on a Wednesday and
pick another thing because remember we
did we did stranger things at one random
day too yeah we can do as many as we
have them put in a chat what you want us
to dress up as I've got court uh Quentin
was hoping for overtime for the Kang
gang we have a great reach down Perry
Clement saying happy Monday happy Monday
happy Monday Tuesday Monday Perry no I
guess it's having my day Christian
unpronounceable wanting for that extra
time for the Kang bang we can't call it
that thank you Brian K hi and Colton
it's King on laying action anyway
uh hot cold suggesting time is about an
infinite Pizza you know it is a flat
circle times a flat circle a little bit
I just can I say something really quick
yeah you guys say something really quick
you guys no one was attacking me you're
fighting in the chat hey stop thank you
for reading no they were being nice they
were being nice they were fighting for
me and yes you can and then uh Hannah
came at me again about being blind and
my glasses are really bad yes they are
you are completely they're just for the
show folks they're just for show
response it's it's alarming this lens is
the bad one because I have a wonky eye
want yeah you do don't look at it trash
bags that's right maybe Janna is Yvonne
and kahoots in love with King I think oh
I think we're on that one Fred girl's
saying uh Janet has a whole family in
the quantum realm and Kang thinks
Ant-Man is the only one to get him out
so he's targeting the people he loves I
still don't see why Kane can't get out
of this question I think there's one
that I I said it I said it I think it
was that piece of equipment trapped him
down there yes
uh Mikey cheers saying the ending is
Kang asking Scott if he killed him
before is the end of the movie Ant-Man
wins uh that is the line that they've
taken out and I think it's very
interesting yeah I don't I mean the
footage of that trailer kind of leaked a
little bit and people were talking about
it and maybe they were like ah they've
already heard it who should put in a
different what part the part in at d23
in that trailer where they were talking
uh Kang is like have I killed you before
you're an Avenger have I killed you
before which is also weird because you
wouldn't think he'd remember well but it
makes you think that this Kang has gone
to multiple universes or has found a way
to pull things down into the quantum
realm from others banish their four
killings maybe Monroe storm said dress
up as wrestlers oh I think that could be
a good one preferably aw I mean there is
like there is a weird tag team that kind
of haunts the office sometimes there's
these two guys in Luchador Mass we can't
have them on the show they're
problematic uh Kobe Bryant asking do you
think Kevin's Army will be mechanical or
biological
biological I mean it did seem like he
was building a lot of ships yeah robots
would make sense I feel like doombots
are coming so you wouldn't want to waste
the unless they they correlate I mean
they had all John Bots
get it together boys agency if she's if
he's pulling people down to force them
to fight in his army that would be
interesting like an army of Avengers
from other universes that'd be a fun way
to variance he's taken in uh uh Quentin
is questioning you Tommy he said full
Jew you on gold trash tag trash day is
Wednesday here oh well quickly enjoy
another night in your luxury Suite I
guess uh Beware the the where the dreads
saying anyone else think detector kind
of looked like the ten Rings maybe we're
contacting Kang and they didn't have
records of them since they're from the
quantum realm you know there is that
still McGuffin out there of like what
are the ten Rings calling out to uh Wong
notices the signal that it's been
sending out there was a lot of ring work
right those little ships had a ring on
the back some Eternal Vibes too with
those like weird yeah yeah
I definitely think the 10 rings and the
eternals tie together I think an eternal
made to the ring yes that would make a
lot of so I think maybe that yeah like
fastos and then you've got like him
playing with time maybe Kang has dealt
with the eternals before and that's how
we bring them back into the fold see I'm
not such an idiot I know the names of
characters I just didn't understand how
Nathan Nathan Richards became king but
now I get it and I feel so emboldened
not so fastos uh Aaron Burke saying I
love you fetches
it's going to be several kangs
it's gonna be king it's gonna be changed
Dave Owens saying time top chasing after
the Time Bandits and the hot tub time
machine to repair a stitch into whoa
elegant time cup when it kills all those
Confederate soldiers yeah that's a
pretty little Gone in 60 Seconds that's
a pretty cool Mr Phoenix standing for
shot chat thank you TD Jones always
thank you TD Jones and Mr Feeney
frequently in the chat Dave Owens thank
you too and uh Monroe uh whatever your
last name was I can't remember we didn't
get your chat out there because I read
it out loud on the air dress up as
wrestlers I think is a fabulous idea let
me talk to my boys and girls and friends
and enemies and see who's up for it
maybe with a whole office will dress
like wrestling who's the enemy maybe
we'll get dashville to dress like a
wrestling Dave Owens running in only
Kings you did say only Kings and it did
make me think of them I did yeah wow
even my mind is working filthy in the
background you know I don't know what
that's a reference to uh oh
um
it's fun oh okay great yeah uh but thank
you all for joining us today on this
very Ant-Man tastic episode what are
some I would say a surprise this morning
but they did kind of tease it a little
bit yesterday the surprise was what time
it dropped because some of us were 5 30.
yeah they usually drop them like six six
a.m but they did it a little later today
could have slept you know it's a
california-based movie California West
Coast 9 A.M you know it is what it is uh
we thank you guys for joining us today
make sure you hit the like button and
subscribe if you haven't already uh tune
in all this week we got lots of great
sets to cover this week there's lots
going on we're getting very close to
Black Panther maybe some people are
going to be at special events this week
involved with black panther we don't
know it's almost Halloween can you bring
a plus one to those events
we're getting closer and closer to
Halloween always a Brides me
a veil between the living and the dead
gets thinner and thinner and who knows
who will pass through that Veil maybe Me
Maybe you maybe all of us but tune in
all this week right here on the break
room you have a great rest of your
Monday and we'll see you here tomorrow
same time same secret location later
skaters I'll feed the same uh choose
space Morgan off
[Music]
it's true